the worst thing to happen to me on stage
was when I cut my finger off I was doing
a rope trick on stage nice and routine
with very sharp scissors I was about to
cut the rope but I cut the whole tip of
my finger off and the tip of my finger
was sitting on these scissors I started
to get famous blood everywhere and the
audience started to applaud I said
ladies and gentlemen I think I cut my
finger off they take me to the hospital
and mike tyson's cut man was in town and
he sewed my finger back on and you can't
tell us like really amazing but you know
I went over Niagara Falls I was an
imploding building I did all these crazy
things I'm totally safe I do a rope
trick and I end up in the hospital
[Music]
the vanishing airplane my first special
is on ABC introduced in the fall season
and it was really frightening at all the
celebrities at the time the Kate Jackson
and Adam rich from eight is enough and
Howard Cosell all the stars at the ABC
season I introduced and a dineymarie
they were all so professional I didn't I
don't know what to do with my hands it
was like really crazy big but they gave
me this chance this chance to to be be
on TV and my my specialty was really
telling stories with magic I wouldn't
just vanish
a woman in a box i advantage her in a
shower and I do the shower scene from
the movie psycho I would do a sailor
number like on the town kind of the
Bernstein's show I would do amazing
stories that dealt with Sam Spade and
combining magic with things that were
kind of relevant to me at the time after
the ABC show CBS picked me up and I was
telling my story telling magic on these
specials and on the second or third
specialer there was four special I
vanished an airplane and that changed
everything people really enjoyed the big
spectacle of it all this shop will pet
away you'll see as if you were there
with absolutely no camera trips and I
was really surprised by it I thought you
know you like that this big illusion and
you don't like all these stories which
are so important to me and they did they
just like the whole idea of the simple
simple creation simple spectacular thing
and the airplane was the first of those
those events
[Music]
I remember it was the next day
incredible it was like the internet
before the Internet it was like being
viral around the world
then people talked about that illusion
and we had it surrounded by people the
airplane that was a Learjet people
remember it as a 747 and I say okay
that's okay
it was really just a Learjet a smaller
plane but they're surrounded by a whole
audience of people holding hands
blindfolded the silhouette of the
airplane was on the front of the box you
saw the people moving in the airplane
silhouette there and then advantaged and
and it was cool we talked to the people
on in the environment to really make
sure the credibility was there and it
got an amazing reaction taking the magic
outdoors putting it in the world that
was familiar to everybody made a big
difference I think having it on an
airstrip we all been on the airstrip
maybe not walking on the airstrip but
witnessing it in a non theatrical
environment really changed things so I
think that's that's one of the factors
for sure the Statue of Liberty
disappears
after the airplane disappeared and the
reaction at God I said what am I going
to do next how am I going to make this
vital and important and you know all my
magic had a heart to it our only magic
had a kind of a personal meaning and the
airplane didn't it was just a big thing
vanishing so when the idea of the Statue
of Liberty came along it was my
opportunity to share the idea of taking
a freedom for granted to use an illusion
for a metaphorical way and vanishingly a
Statue of Liberty was an amazing amazing
thing we spent a number of years on it I
worked with Frank Capra I asked Frank
Capra to help me write the dialogue from
it and Frank Capra was kind of
cantankerous a very famous fighter you
know he was a diminutive size but he was
this genius of the cinema and one of my
idols and I read to him I said I want to
make a statue who disappear to show how
important our freedom is and he says you
know okay and I said well would you help
me I want you help me write that the
dialogue for this because you're your
studio is Liberty films all the movies
that I loved you made you wrote would
you help me I'll help you but on one
condition that when you attempt to do it
you fail and I said what do you mean
this is all your gonna try to do this
thing you'll set up the whole thing and
you got to try to do it and you're going
to show that Liberty cannot disappear
and you're gonna fail and I said well
mr. Capra I think CBS won't like this
idea and I spent four hours arguing with
Frank Capra believe it or not and I saw
the same guy that would fight the head
of the studio Harry Cohen you know to
try to get his way on his films I got to
experience that as as a 20 year old you
know silly kid but finally I convinced
him finally I convinced him and he
helped me write the dialogue for that
segment of the show where it talks about
how important our freedom is and how we
take it for granted and so forth so I
had Frank Capra it's my co-writer on the
Statue of Liberty vanish I thought if we
faced emptiness where for as long as we
can remember that great lady has lifted
up her leg
why then we might imagine what the world
would be like without liberty and we'd
realize how precious our freedom really
is but that was only one problem the
real problem is getting permission to do
it the park department said no you know
and I think they were right you know
here's this guy saying I make the statue
disappear will you help me do it and the
parks department said we don't want you
to go get out of here and I said well
please I've got this great idea finally
I was doing lots of shows at Ford's
Theater in Washington for various
different presidents and Reagan was the
president at the time and I became kind
of friendly with Ronald ray and I said
I've got this idea of showing how
important our freedom is and how fragile
it is and how we shouldn't take it for
granted
and will you help me can I get
permission everyone said no to me
he thought of had and he said okay you
should go for it so I Ronald Regan me
permission to to vanish the Statue of
Liberty which is pretty pretty awesome
so I got for our egg and I got Frank
Capra and I've got this big beautiful
lady you know in the harbor there that
I've got to make disappear so then we
had to figure out how to do it and make
it really wonderful and then we did and
it worked out pretty good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it was really really great and it really
kind of is one of our things and in our
cultural time and it was it was torture
for me the whole thing was torture but
it was glorious torture how I was it was
really worth doing that jacket will
probably not be seen in GQ this month
bill blue was the designer of the
costumer for the show and that jacket
he's the same guy that did the Elvis the
famous Elvis high collar you know thing
kind of iconic I think it's due for a
comeback walking through the Great Wall
of China
I was I was looking to take magic and
bring it further than where it come from
before you know Houdini had walked
through a brick wall on stage and a
friend of mine said you know Houdini did
that I think you've got to walk through
the wall what does it do all in the
world it's probably the Great Wall of
China built the key keep farming's from
going through so we started working on
that idea and the idea of collaborating
with the Chinese government and the
Chinese television networks was a
interesting challenge too and we went
there we went there slightly before Big
Bird went there and collaborated with
them and it was really a wonderful
experience they've never seen a lot of
the same equipment boy they had the best
equipment they could afford it but they
didn't know how to use it so we taught
them how to use steadicams
we had a luma crane this big crane that
would do the whole illusion in one shot
without cutting away that was very
important to make the magic credible
we'd have to show the entire vision
without any cuts or breaks in it and
there was a crane developed develop at
the time there was the newest thing
called the luma crane which was a head
that could turn camera head they can
turn and they could move any way you
wanted to move and we brought that to
China and it was it was really really
cool and we worked side-by-side with the
Chinese technicians and so forth
I understand now how the Great Wall was
built now because I saw there is no osha
in China there is no rules of safety in
China at least at the time so you'd have
200 people climbing on top of each other
carrying gigantic crates over the wall
it was incredible and you don't care
about safety um but they were able to
accomplish stuff you could never imagine
you know here we have all these rules at
that time there was no rules and it was
really eye-opening a little bit scary
but it was pretty cool
I would always layer things in my
illusions you know with the Statue of
Liberty I had cameras I was promoting
Kodak cameras at the time corex Polaroid
camera they had their own version of
polar they later got sued for two
billion dollars in lost to the Polaroid
corporation because they kind of took
too much of the patent but I was their
representative at the time the coda yeah
so I had all these cameras around the
statue simultaneously taking these
instant pictures around the thing I did
the same thing at the great wall we had
radar and you hear my heart beat as they
went over the whole wall we fought many
layers of ideas were important to make
it more credible
[Music]
you know we had the wall inspected and
you know the walls lots of its in
disrepair it's kind of sad and but it's
really beautiful what's what's good
about it is very beautiful and it did
stop Genghis Khan from coming through
but not this little Jewish kid from New
Jersey you know I was able to get
through there
[Music]
but I think having all those different
steps made it better you know we had a
moment where I was trying to push
through it in two to two spandex and you
know today of course I would do it in a
different way you know you always look
back and go I wish I'd changed that or
that you know I get reactor would look
at performance ago I wish I didn't do
that but you know overall I think it's a
it's it's pretty good work well always
different haircuts always that the
Escape from Alcatraz
this must have been inspired by the Uni
at least in part Houdini was probably
the iconic escape artists you know the
person that that made that idea
important you know I'd done a few
different escapes but that would seem
Alcatraz seems to be you know pretty
formidable challenge and we did it as
layers and layers and layers
how would you escape from guard dogs you
know you'd produce a cat how would you
get out of a cell that had a certain
kind of lock or you'd form a key with
your hands to to make it how would you
get through a bars will you penetrate
through them of course you would and
then the end how would you get off of an
island that's shark-infested waters and
very cold water and then the bay what
would you do and you know you have to
become a guard you know and I became a
guard at the end disguise myself and it
took my cat there's some really unique
illusions in that thing really you know
the penetration through the the bars is
is pretty good
the the cat production is pretty good
and my getting away at the end of this
is not bad
to make it interesting I had timed
explosives or in the cell and the
hallway they would go off to give a
little bit of a kind of a ticking clock
effect and I'd rehearse the straitjacket
escape the whole thing I was a Hurst on
stage I had a cell onstage I had the
straight check out on stage even the
ending scene I would do on stage as I
would travel to kind of prepare for this
and I did that with every special I
wouldn't just go and shoot a TV special
I'd do it live so I hear the audience
reaction I get used to doing it and they
escape from a straight check and was
with it with with a bomb in the cell
with me and when I went to Alcatraz the
timing was different and I didn't know
why the time he was different and I
would get out and the time was wrong and
I realized that on stage when I would do
it there was an exit sign in the back of
every theater there's many exercises I
had focus on that exercise
and I'd escaped focusing on exercise and
I would get out in a certain amount of
time but in Alcatraz there are no exit
signs and it changed everything
it changed how I did the piece so look
at next time you're in prison you'll see
no exercise using a helicopter was the
only way to not get caught that would be
my theory of this whole thing so in
order to be have a helicopter available
that have to be a helicopter that was
trying to keep me in as supposed to keep
me out so for me to become a guard to
transform into a guard to be found all
in one camera shot if you look from the
beginning if I get into this box there's
no cuts the box blows up the camera
looks underneath the table goes follows
the guards out of the building try to
find me and I get in the helicopter and
I'm gone so all that is one complete
shot no cuts on Alcatraz which is pretty
awesome I got to sleep in Al Capone cell
the cell that escaped from was Alvin
creepy car pieces so it's pretty pretty
pretty fun and we had real guards there
who were there at the time of those guys
you know they were in their 70s or 80s
at the time but they were kids kid
guards there it was so much fun hanging
out with them and learning about the
whole experience there it's a kind of
amazing place
the explosive encounter
he won an Emmy for your costume I did
what was my costume
we've won 21 Emmys which is pretty cool
I didn't realize the costume from my
explosive building illusion was one of
but it's interesting that escape was
really awesome me to do there's only one
take you can only do it once we asked
permission to use a church parking lot
to shoot it from you can see the
building from this church parking lot
and a church said no they thought magic
was demonic or they have some kind of
anti spiritual thing with what I was
doing and I explained no no I'm an
illusionist I'm trying to bring joy to
the world I this is not you know nothing
like that this and no we talked to our
board we're not going you can't use the
our church parking lot to shoot this
thing huh well hundreds of thousands
dollars later because we had to shoot in
another direction we had to shoot it
from a roof of a garage was the other
other angle of the building together
churches over here the building was here
in order to do that you'd have to go and
rent the camera crane to go across the
parking lot and up to these to the top
of this parking lot over here to be able
to shoot it okay so the church cost me a
lot of money even though I'm sure they
were a little nervous about me using the
parking light anyway so we do this
illusion and the illusion is I should
they call him escape takes place in one
camera shot and the McConkey brothers
mikake brothers did bonfire of the
vanities and Goodfellas all these long
very famous camera shots which they did
after my thing so it is kind of cool
my thing was broadcast before any of
those very famous Scorsese movies are
were done with these fantastic camera
shots but they are the ones that show me
getting into the safe backed out of the
building onto the camera can onto a
building all in one take to see if I
escaped or not that day there was a lot
of wind we couldn't turn back we did the
escape and they run out of the building
and the winds blowing
and they get on top of the thing and the
wind as the Billy implodes with no
retakes obviously implodes and becomes
dust and that dust blows right over the
church
[Music]
we would have had no escape would have
been a total bust because if we were to
get permission from the church and shoot
from the church parking lot where we
wanted to and see that a building
implode the desk would have blown over
us no illusion it would look like a
camera check look camera cut so you
watch if you watch the video you'll see
that the whole building blows to the
side and that's where we want this shoot
so you know I we thank the church Church
did the right thing for us and we
appreciate their efforts
music is very important to everything I
do it everything if you look at every
piece of work that I've I've done music
is you know I I study it like Tarantino
and he makes a movie you know and I
heard he does I said that's why that's
what I do
I just really spend years to find the
right piece of music for each little
thing I always thought the whole idea of
ability imploding was sort of classical
in nature it's just to watch a building
go in slow motion like that was operatic
it was it was classical I found a a
Mozart piece I thought would really fit
that and it starts out with me putting a
DVD in the DVD remember DVDs there's a
little round diskeeper than a thing and
anyway I put it aside as a DVD
new-fangled a and you start the DVD in
it it begins all of the action and it
ends off with talking heads
I think burning down the house it's kind
of obvious an obvious play off music is
really key about this and the whole
juxtaposition between this piece of
classical music and these brilliant
camera operators running out of a
building and people call quoting up
cable because you couldn't have there's
no radio control or you know Bluetooth
connection to the thing you couldn't
trust it maybe this connection during
this one chance of having a building
implode contrasting with his music
that's classical I thought was kind of
nice and yeah it was a good day
the Niagara Falls challenge
what things in our life that we can
visually see are formidable challenges a
building implosion is pretty durable a
waterfall like Niagara Falls seem to be
a good adversary you know so he designed
it a whole whole thing where I had to
slowly get out of a contraption going
down the rapids into you know Niagara
Falls and with a jet ski that I have to
get on to go back and we put tracks into
the rapids of Niagara Falls a week
before we were issued this and he
steagle thick tracks became like
spaghetti
they literally twisted in the current
steel and I didn't sleep for the whole
week up to shooting this thing we had to
find another way of doing this and just
the fear of that much power was
something we didn't expect and planned
for so instead of going down a ramp into
the rapids we had to be placed with a
helicopter and drop to the helicopter in
there also not very good it was every
night was really sleepless for me it was
really not I thought it was going to be
that this is going to be you know the
end of it but we did it prior to that we
rehearsed this ending with me on a rope
coming up from the falls and we hired a
stunt person to do rehearsal so he'd
shoot rehearsals with a stump I've
obviously I was gonna do that real event
we got a stunt person to do the
rehearsals of it and he did it once and
then he refused to do it after that and
I said why and him and the helicopter
pilot said we have no out strategy when
you have a helicopter didn't do a
helicopter stunts there's a ground
underneath you and you can somehow land
onto the ground
but hovering over rocks and a waterfall
there's no house strategy you're done
there's not even a chance of doing this
so I was the only one that got to do it
and because I'm stupid it was amazing
you know it was just amazing imagine
holding on to a rope and having Niagara
Falls 3 feet in front of you literally
the waters rushing down like this giant
force of nature literally force of
nature like a curtain in front and
splashing you and would Nagre faucet and
coming of it it's unbelievable
no one I don't get to experience that
nobody and the amazing thing is my hair
was totally dry magic hang on to a rope
coming up from the bottom middle of
Niagara Falls was the most dangerous
part of the whole thing really at the
end of the day but it was a horrifying
beginning and a very happy relieved
ending don't have to do it again yeah
yeah we did a lot of stupid things
living on fire you know I was supposed
to get out before that you know kind of
Perils of Pauline you know I have to get
out before jet ski back which of course
didn't work out but we had fire you know
all that stuff going when it was done it
was a really thing I I just don't have
to do again
fly history is very important to all of
us you know I like seeing the root of
things what came before me what what
challenges people have had before in the
flying loser we had film which had been
seen before but kind of interesting to
see together people attempting to fly
and failing the amazing thing is those
people invited news crews to see them
fly with their airplanes contraptions
wings orth and they never tested it
who would invite the press to come see
you when you hadn't rehearsed it maybe
because of my magician I think things
through carefully that I'll rehearse and
try and test and double-check look at
the takes before and before inviting the
world to see it well these people
invited the world to see them and they
failed miserably and comedic ly a bit
but they brought people to see them when
they weren't sure that was gonna work so
we thought that was good and it was kind
of in contrast to this really kind of
poetic flying that I developed
I think the flying illusion changed
magic in many ways because it really
became an aspirational thing it wasn't
you don't wake up in the morning and
want to make it hell but disappear I
don't think anybody wakes up I'd like to
saw my girlfriend in half you know I
don't that's not normal I don't think
but flying people do dream about you
know so to do that illusion to do it
just this I wanted to be as good as a
dream that people have and if I did that
people would respond in a very strong
way and they did people would gonna get
emotional in the audience watching me
fly men would cry when they watch me fly
the music played a part of it but also
just the fact that I made it look like I
imagined it you know and I am it and
it's a huge dream of mine it's a dream
shared by many people
[Music]
because I'm a magician
I couldn't just fly I had to prove there
were no wires or magnets or anything
like that so it looks for every single
way to disprove it
you know we had hoops you know around me
we had a plexiglass box because that's
the most understandable way of
containing the object that we'll be
flying
it's something that we developed my
father in fact suggested this particular
hoop pass that could work these two
hoops that were linked together that was
my father's idea so I kind of looked
back and kind of smiled thank him you
know prefer for that contribution
[Music]
you know unlike a film director I have a
team of people we collaborate ideas we
test things and trial and error that
took about seven years to get that right
that illusion but it was worth it you
know it really still looks pretty good
having a bird fly with me and just to
kind of be an aspirational thing that I
would fly with we toured for 20 years
without Ellucian and we travel with the
bird too you know we'd have an eagle
with his own bunk in the bus with a
camera off and which he is a free flight
bird he would fly around the city and
fly back to us with using falconry the
falconry kind of system of that you know
today I probably wouldn't do it because
I feel a bit differently about using
animals in the in entertainment but at
the time it was it was cool them and it
was really a really quite quite
beautiful thing in England Princess Di
came to the show with William and Harry
they were 11 and 13 years old
and I flew as the finale of my show and
it went horribly wrong so they're in the
audience and I begin this piece by
levitating up and I'm frozen in the air
immobile can't move and I don't know
what to do I look out of the crowd there
they are
and the audience can't hear me because
when Mike is off for them but my crew
could hear me and I say close the
curtain please and the curtain slowly
painfully closed like this and I say
leave my mic on I'm talking to the
audience through the curtain and ladders
are coming out to allow me to not be
suspended in the air frozen in space as
they're getting me down I said ladies
gentlemen stay in your seats it's gonna
take five minutes I want you to see this
piece because I really think it's it's
pretty good
and five minutes take place and I
continue to fly and it goes beautifully
so I had oil tea in the audience and on
stage a royal portal
what he gonna do when you've done so
much stuff you know well you're gonna
teleport people I want to tell about
people make it you know trans coastal
you know or go from one country to
another leave if he can make that
credible and believable how would you do
that to make an audience really
convinced even for that moment that
you're transporting somebody in a Star
Trek fashion to another place can you
make that happen so that's a big
challenge for me so we spent two years
on that you know on the road and after
every show I'd interview people after
the show what did you believe what
didn't you believe what you hate was
that credible and just define what
little proofs wouldn't make it so it
will be acceptable and believable you
know whether it's a signature on your
body that would match what you'd see in
the other place a Polaroid that would
match that exists what would be the
things that would convince you that it
was really happening and not just one
big camera trick that illusion the
portal illusion was a big arm that was
over the audience so I'm not vanishing a
person onstage I'm benching over the
audience suspended with me an ax person
vanishing pretty good it's pretty good
illusion totally invented from scratch
doesn't exist in any magic book and so
that illusions got to be good and the
reappearance has to be good and the
credibility of whether the person really
went someplace else has to be believable
so years of trial and error of getting
people's opinions and finally you get it
to work and finally people believe it
and then you have to bring the person
back or I've got to come back from that
remote island so I thought what layer's
go put on that it'll be raining on the
island and I'll make it rain when I come
back it's gonna rain in the theaters
people are kind of you know welcoming
the rain coming back from the Hawaiian
island or the Bahamian or wherever I
went that time so it was a amazing idea
that reached very very far and fun got
it to be workable and acceptable I've
done Rian's a lot in my work my current
live show has me and my father kind of
making amends
in Assam way spoiler alert you know
forget about this when you come see my
show but it's a it's a theme that
somehow I keep coming back to you know I
guess I like Field of Dreams you know I
think I it's it struck me you know my my
mother my father you know I was an only
child so those that that relationship
keeps informing a lot of my storytelling
and and that's okay they say write what
you know
and I know that the mystery of the 15
star
I've been doing a lot of work with the
Smithsonian it's a fantastic
organization larger than you could
possibly imagine this I'm thousands of
museums all over that are supervised by
them that they're helping with our
efforts to help the people in the
Bahamas right now we're working on
saving the culture with the Smithsonian
I'm doing they're just great people and
they wanted me to do an event with them
and we discussed this on Flag Day they
have the star-spangled banner the
star-spangled banner is an actual flag
that's Francis Scott Key saw waving with
the bombs bursting in midair and wrote
our national anthem the actual flags the
size of this room you guys can't see it
at home but the size this was gigantic
flag it's missing a star is missing the
15 star and they told me it's missing a
15 star and of course I'm me so I go
okay
now you're in my world now I got to do
something with that I can probably make
that star reappear so I want to work a
year later I have a illusion where I can
reproduce this star that's missing in an
in my own metaphorical way show how
important us being United is and how you
know cooperation between States and
cultures and all this coming together in
one unified form we are stronger that
way each star represents a state in our
Union so to restore that star has a
great value and that illusion of
restored make that star appear also as
part of the day where we're naturalizing
15 citizens so we have immigrants coming
here becoming citizens on the same day
I'm making that star up here so it was a
really a warm kind of thing to do and
the English is not bad and it's such
it's in my wheelhouse for sure currently
we're working on things that are really
really remarkable life I love technology
I love taking technology and art
combining them together in my show now I
have spaceships and dinosaurs and aliens
and time travel things that aren't in
the magic books that exist but we're
developing new things and new technology
which you're going to get to use someday
I
he's it for a while to make make it
wonderful but eventually it'll be part
of you know human life but it's really
really awesome you know and in magic
that's been a pattern you know magicians
have used radios and communication
devices to read people's minds then now
we have a cellphone you know but this
existed as a the first smart home to
exist was a magic trick of though the
door that opens by itself was an
electromagnet magic effect now every
grocery store has it so magicians are at
the forefront of creating new technology
which eventually they can't use anymore
it becomes part of the real world and
I'm doing that right now
you know this illusions that are really
wonderful that I'm working on which are
which you'll have actual use in in
society someday but first I get to
exploit them as pieces of wonder
[Music]